before we go we need to end off on some
good vibes fish after that dark trailer
and what's more exciting than the home
alone reboot i didn't even know this is
a thing so even though macaulay culkin
won't be reprising his iconic role as
kevin mcallister you know i'm very
disappointed by that the new version
will not disappoint with stars like
keenan thompson and ellie kempfer uh
yeah and the new film follows the
mischievous max mercer who has been left
behind after his family takes off to
japan for the holidays here's your first
look at home sweet home alone before
premieres on disney plus on november
12th thanks
it was the night before christmas
vacation
and the fun was in full swing you split
our family onto two separate flights mom
please the family left for their big
vacation is that everyone the cars are
leaving now but forgot one little thing
mum
dad uncle blake
they don't even know i'm here
they don't even know i'm here
my mom and dad have gone to tokyo i'm
totally on my own
[Music]
you do realize that my ten-year-old son
is at home by himself you just assumed
max was on the other flight we didn't
take a census
we got reports of suspicious people
around 36 lincoln have
i can't go to jail honey i wouldn't last
30 seconds in gen pomp that's where
fresh fish get got nobody here is
getting
got
and we're criminals i don't think so
this is my house i have to defend it
orange stripe
[Music]
that did not sound right
i am trying to get home to my son
who is alone
i'm scared
and he needs his mother
nothing's going well
home sweet home alone oh no a ladder you
think i'm that stupid
[Music]
yes i do